hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to tasty planet now you
may all think of me as the incredibly
handsome undeniably intelligent an
all-around cool guy that is markiplier
but even I make stupid mistakes because
apparently this game was on Steam and I
didn't even know it
I had like a goat hooked up with an
auxilary cord up its ass and then tied
to my Elgato
and then all swirled up in a mix of
[ __ ] I didn't need it it was just
motivating me as a let's player and then
I didn't need that cuz it's here so I'm
gonna play and I'm gonna pick up right
where I last left off which is eating
dinosaurs because if there's a way to go
back in time and be a douchebag the
dinosaurs
this guy's gonna find it and where the
hell am I supposed to do there's no one
here they're already dead oh god I gotta
pick their bones I thought I already
went back to the part where they're all
alive I thought I was gonna have a fun
old-time prehistoric here where they're
gonna be the baddest that could eat I
mean it's kind of a dick thing to do but
that's kind of my primary objective for
being out here is to be the biggest
douchebag possible and destroy the
entire world YUM I guess munching on old
bones always a good delightful meal for
me I mean if I'd have known that this
was all I was supposed to do on the
get-go I would have had a better start
about it because I actually did play
through this game again just to be able
to get where I am on the Steam version
of it am i speaking too fast for you
guys to understand I just got back from
pax and holy hell am I tired I am
unbelievably unquestionably
astonishingly tired oh my god I just had
turbo mode haters see you later holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened I mean
there's no one live so I guess we're
doing generally okay being the horrible
time terrorist that we are we take that
hip bone hip bone connected to my
stomach okay but anyway so I just got
back from pax and it was a great time
got to spend a lot of time with my
friends again and hang out with you guys
and I'm really grateful for that because
it's always a humbling experience to be
able to meet so many of you guys and we
did a great job at the the panel and
then the take over the Polaris booth all
the videos are up on YouTube somewhere
if I find them I'll put the links in the
description below but then again I'm
very tired it's currently 3 & 3 343 in
the [ __ ] morning
and woo why am i [ __ ] a video game to
be in the morning where I'm having
maniacal thoughts I have a feeling that
this this game is gonna leave an imprint
on my brain and I'm gonna secretly start
eating my pillow and then growing bigger
and bigger and not so sensual sue always
excuse me sorry so we ate up some not
what the good sorry
excuse me I'm losing my goddamn mind
okay
this makes sense I don't think the level
distribution is entirely intelligent on
this and I don't think these grubs
appreciate me being a goddamn [ __ ]
[ __ ] to them and eating them
you think they assimilate into me do you
think they know do you think it's a
horrible painful experience when I
consume them into my gullet probably is
hey sure back off he's mine get out of
the way I need to eat bored ow
goddamn it [ __ ] hater okay I need
more grasshoppers to block out the
haters my uh the reason it's so late and
the reason that I'm playing this is
because I timed this exactly so I would
run out of videos exactly when I came
back but my flight got delayed I didn't
get here soon enough
so the bra ha ha yeah see you later
hater you ain't gonna give me trough
sock me what was that oh my god it's
dinos that is the stupidest run I've
ever seen what are you what are you you
know frankly I'm glad that I'm eating
your Oh God go away hater shields at
maximum oh [ __ ] they want me bad I mean
I don't blame them I am incredibly
handsome and astonishingly smart and
good talk Ernest do that I have by shrew
screw you turtle you are alright but you
do better in my ah haters hate her
oh god I like my hater shields can
withstand hate of this magnitude it's
such happy music it's so happy
god it's so happy
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you die knows you
gonna get it go get it eventually you're
gonna get it in like two oh you better
run Oh too late for you you couldn't run
fast enough I'm very tired but I had a
great time at PAX you know I didn't get
to see much of the show floor but I did
get to see the preview for all God Oh
Lee [ __ ] everybody hold on to your hands
because things got crazy oh my god it's
like the dinosaur bone that I ate before
is that a continuation of it this is all
like a continuous stream of the same
thing oh god those poor bird dinos I
hate it when they squawk right before I
swallow them whole and then mush their
bodies into more gray goo da OH
oh we got a level 99 a hater coming in
he's gonna get us down away now the wait
block me save me I don't know the names
of dinosaur it's been a long time since
i IE even thought about that
gimme oh that was a squishy rock why was
that rock
so squash I don't want to know excuse me
pardon me
ouch don't mind me boo-boo and myself
while I eat again
yummy yummy dinos oh god did I mention
that my brains not exactly working right
now so don't expect any high quality
commentary this late into the day and
I'm gonna record more after this because
why the [ __ ] not holy crap Oh ha
apparently this gray goo is Jewish hey I
don't know what I do I'm gonna be
offensive no matter what I do so I'm
gonna stop right there just carry on I'm
not gonna stop playing the game mom stop
right there oh I did the beach oh how
lovely I can't go anywhere goddamn I'm
waterfowl oh that's clever
not really I mean I'm just walking on
Lilly I'm not calling myself clever I'm
calling the game clever it's a different
way of having an environment so that it
stays nice and diverse so I don't get
too bored
it's not too late for me to talk about
game design here Wow okay
bye what opossums I'm kind of confused
as to what time period that I keep
jumping around into because before I was
on the understanding to these turtles
with historic and stuff the things that
you seem to be awfully modern I mean not
that I'm complaining about anything but
because I'm a freaking grey goo that's
gonna cause the apocalypse I mean what
do I have to complain about him friggin
awesome look at me
whatever was I talking about there we go
we've made progress we moved on to
sticks which means that eventually we'll
move on turts
but they're coming later don't worry
about it no creep done they just came on
the beach to breed and have love and
meet their wives and husbands out on a
nice beachfront date well too bad death
for you huh okay what bugs did that that
one turtle was loaded up with crack here
we go holy [ __ ] why are there dinosaur
bones it still doesn't make any goddamn
sense that there are dinosaur bones is
laying about uh-huh okay alright I
blacked out for a second there I
seriously like my brain went somewhere
else I'm pretty sure I just fell asleep
halfway through that this let's play I
have no idea what just happened I zoned
out completely as I was watching that
crocodile and my brain was like ah my
brain wasn't like ah I just went fast
again and every time I go fast it just
throws me for a loop but my brain was
like looking at the crocodile and being
like that's a dopey ass crocodile I
should say something about that
and then I blanked out for too long and
then forgot about what I was what am I
talking about
okay ah too late for you crocodile this
is your time oh you thought you were at
the top of the food chain little did you
know the high who's at the top of the
food snicky ah ah okay there we go
got it whoo I am so I'm not holding it
together everybody I am losing it I'm
losing and the reason why I don't have
to be quiet this late in the morning is
cuz no one else is here I'm all alone
unless I'm not alone which would be very
creepy all things considered but maybe
not okay let's just assume that it's not
that way that it is so let's keep going
eat a hundred and ten eggs what I have
an objective now I don't like objectives
don't tell me what to do I don't even
know what eggs look like those weren't
rocks Oh God
I thought I was eating rocks the whole
time I didn't know I was eating actual
eggs I by the way there's a little hard
to control I Maggie see I tried a whole
bunch of different things because on the
phone it had tilt controls but now I'm
the computer dad love both the mouse and
keyboard and then I said [ __ ] it to both
of those and why with a goddamn gamepad
which isn't any better it's actually
quite imprecise if I had to say so the
mouse is very precise and I mean here
I'll show you look at what the mouse go
on god bad timing for the mouse but look
at them the mouse can do right am i
right sorry mama
I just hate all your babies don't worry
about a thing you just go be sad in a
corner but it's goddamn infuriating
because I have to keep walking picking
it up and scrolling it around so might
as well just play keep-away with these
dinos as they try to stop me from eating
their young which of course I'm not
gonna do I'm gonna keep doing it as long
as I can keep breathing much I don't
even know if I breathe I'm kind of a
mechanical monstrosity that that one
just disappeared in front of me but I'm
kind of like you know just not really
here
not really anyway maybe I could just
ignore the eggs and eat the adults would
that be the more humane thing to do I
mean besides the emotional trauma that
I'm inflicting on these poor I mean look
at them they're just trying to defend
their own this game is horrible this
game makes you do terrible terrible
things why disease being done Oh
I mean seriously they probably just love
their family so much Oh God oh that was
it
well my reign of terror is over and I
did what I came to do which is ruin
everything this guy whoo let's do one
more you see one more
well bigger than dinos what could be
bigger than oh I'm gonna be bigger than
dinos well I should have evaluated my
thoughts better before I actually opened
my goddamn mouth which is not something
that I'm good at doing right now I mean
not opening my goddamn mouth but
evaluating what my brain is dripping out
through my nose and mouth ah get away
hey goddamn hater Patrol here figured
stop me huh I'm 2 bytes away from eating
your but specifically the but I don't
like anything else but - but what I'd
like to think that all these dinosaurs
are just trying to check up on their
friends that didn't get back to them
like they all went into this valley and
they're like huh Geoffrey's gone
well better go over there to make sure
that he's okay oh [ __ ] oh god it's a
horrible gray goo from the future and we
have the mental capacity to understand
that threat oh god I'm gonna eventually
eat the mastodon then them do you new I
don't know the name of that so I'm going
to God that you get rich until it come
the collectable
more the phlegm and Bobo Moe bramish
rambro sorry were you eating those
leaves well [ __ ] were you eating the you
I'm sorry were you using that body I
apologize
not really oh this is getting bad oh
this is getting real bad oh this is
getting oh god oh god oh yeah
Oh I just realized it's just like dawned
on me what I was doing I'm destroying
the entire planet at this rate Oh God
let me just circle that tree for a few
laps of shame what is this oh can I eat
that am I gonna eat a volcano I mean
eventually it's gonna be me eating
landmasses not actually creatures I got
damnit you learned my one weakness small
holes sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry can I eat these yet tonight God
God if I can't eat the goddamn trees
what am I gonna be doing give give give
give yes yes yes yes yes yes why yes
like the entire population yes no
survivors yes way yes even the even the
ecology of here the flora of the plant
Katina the fun oh wow okay
well that's a lot of species that got
done distinct so that's all the time
that I got for tasty planet right now
I'm gonna record more of this god I'm a
masochist I don't need sleep
no one needs sleep no one needs to do
anything but play video games for the
rest of their life so you heard it first
pray for markiplier free free from
markiplier don't do your homework stay
in school
drink your milk eat your ah ignore
everything I just said I'm bad role
model to kids so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
yeah this is ed OH got 50 rats three
cats Oh